all right well this is Jack as you know
right all right what we do at the
sandpit today I'm going to attend the
front flip and how do you do how do you
do a front that was your technique my
technique is I take about five to six
metres brother yes and then I jump in
the air go upside down and hopefully
land on my feet
do you ever land like this would it be
take one
right well I better give this a go then
I think so this is not going to go well
Oh Erica
Jack do a backflip yeah clonk front flip
I guess back for mr. Mixon I'm not gonna
try this one I think you should because
I like my neck go for it
mmm Jack I think we should give it one
of our world famous double Superman's
what do you recognize yeah all right
let's do it
all right there I'm just hijacking the
end of this video quickly firstly thanks
to Dredd skull for the suggestion for
this video and secondly due to the fact
we've hit a million views I'm going to
do a question and answer video because I
get a lot of questions in the comments
of these videos which I've tried to
answer but there's just so many and the
answers get lost and stuff so basically
if you want to ask any question about
the slow mo guys put it in the comments
of this front flip back flip video and
they will be answered in an upcoming
video so well that's it
subscribe